And, again, it is the first part of January 2019. Welcome to our Zoom call. And we have
some questions that came in that I want to go over first and we'll open it up for questions
for everybody. So first we had some questions that came in about vitamin C IV therapy. If you
think that's a good thing, what should I start it with, how often should I do it, etc.
in what type of vitamin C should I use? So let's go over some of those questions. So vitamin C
IV therapy can be a good addition to what you are doing. We don't do it in our office
simply because the majority of our patients are not local to us. And we do have a local
clinic that we refer to that doesn't, so no sense in duplicating services. However vitamin C IV therapy
can be beneficial, but it's just like any other therapy, whether you're doing mushrooms or
mistletoe, or protocell, or anything else. It's therapy that we test for. So we've tested every
person that has been here for it, and some people we've told to continue doing it or to do vitamin
C therapy, and some people we have not spoken to them about it because it didn't test out the
testing. Does that mean that a person shouldn't do it because they're not tested for it? Well that's
an option that you have to make yourself. Again, too much of a good thing is a bad thing. So too many
different nutritional things that you're putting in your body can be a negative. Now remember,
vitamin C taken orally and a normal dose is considered an antioxidant.
Some of the current belief of high dose vitamin C IV therapy is that it is actually acting
as an oxidizing agent. What's the difference between those two things and why do I need to know that?
Well, it's how it's acting in the body. Chemotherapy acts as an oxidizing agent as well.
So if you're doing chemotherapy, most colleges say don't do vitamin C therapy. They don't want you
to do IV vitamin C because you don't want to give an antioxidant if you're giving a high dose
oxidant. We talked about this before, but the current thought process is that high dose vitamin C,
what you'd receive at an IV is not an antioxidant but an oxidizing agent. So it is arguable whether you
could do that with chemotherapy or not. It does act like a chemotherapy agent is what I'd say.
So it does have some benefits, has some side effects too. It can affect your veins especially if
you have small arms, small veins in your treaty person. It can burn out your veins especially at
a higher dose. Let's talk about dosage. So first of all, I think you should be tested for it whether
you should use it or not, but if you really feel it inkling, you really feel like the Holy Spirit
is really pulling you towards doing it. And by all means, you should certainly consider it as a
therapy choice and consider doing it. If you do do it, I would suggest that you start at a low dose.
Now, what is the type of dose that is used for IV vitamin C? So IV vitamin C, many people,
many practitioners that do it, try to get their patients up to 75 grams, that's 75,000 milligrams,
75 grams per dose, which is very high. And depending on your body type and your weight,
that might be too high. In fact, there's new research out that shows that you don't need to go that high
in a dose. Also, with any IV therapy, it depends on how long the drip is for. So if you're going to
push 20 grams, which is considered a low dose of IV vitamin C, for an hour, that's a nice low dose
drip. If you're going to push 20 grams of IV vitamin C for half an hour, that's equivalent to getting 40 grams
in an hour, to understand. So the length of the drip, so it partly depends on the clinic you go to.
Some clinics, if they're really busy, they're trying to rush people through because numbers are
muddy, might not be in the best interest of the patient. So you're either you're better off going
slower drip, lower dose to begin with, and slower frequency, like at once a week to begin with.
Now, the other part of the question that we had to commit was what type of vitamin C is the right
vitamin C for an IV drip? Well, you really don't have a choice. The only vitamin C that's going to be
at a high dose in a drip is going to be synthetic ascorbic acid. You can't get a whole food
vitamin C in that type of dose in an IV bag. It doesn't exist. So you are getting synthetic
ascorbic acid, which is technically simply the outer shell of the whole food vitamin C molecule
found in nature, but that ascorbic acid portion has been found effective in some people with cancer.
So I wouldn't shy away from it just simply because it is ascorbic acid. I would just be careful
moving up my dose. You might want to start at 20 grams, move up to 25 grams after several weeks,
and you can tolerate it just fine, and you might stay at 25 grams, and that's all you will do.
If your clinic is pushing you to go higher, feel free to give us a call and talk to us about that.
If you are at a higher body weight, you are a bigger person. There's no reason why you can't go
up to 35, 45, 50 grams. I don't know why it would be necessary for anybody to get up to 75 grams.
Next questions that came in were on THC, Rick Simpson oil and CBD oil. They're really on the THC oil.
That's called Rick Simpson oil. THC tetrahydrochlorobinoid is the, excuse me, I just said,
decubinoid, but the THC is the tetra portion of the cannabinoid, which is from marijuana.
And it has been nicknamed Rick Simpson oil because Rick Simpson, the gentleman from Canada,
is one who really put it on the map. I don't know if he actually discovered how to create the oil
that way or not, but really sure of the history, but his name is behind it. It comes in a black paste
like substance here. It is legal to be had in most states that have legalized marijuana.
The problem, there's some problems with it as well. So if you look at the internet with THC oil or
Rick Simpson oil or also known as RSO oil, it can be labeled as the cancer cure. Everybody that has
cancer should use it and it cures all forms of cancer and it's magic and it makes all your problems
go away and et cetera. So you know the facts about that might believe about that. Nothing does
that. Nothing works for everybody. But Rick Simpson oil is a treatment of choice for cancer. It's
another nutraceutical for cancer, and if you test out well for it, I would suggest you try it.
But even at that, even if you test out that RSO oil will work for you, does not mean
you can tolerate it. So let's talk about that just a wee bit.
So it is THC, which is the psychoactive portion of the marijuana plant.
And it is very, very concentrated, and it comes out in a tube like this and you're supposed to get up
to a grandma day, which is equivalent of about three grades of rice. Depending on the dosage that's
found in that oil itself, it can be three grades of rice three times a day of the dose that you're
supposed to get up to with this stuff. The problem with it is that there, you know people are making
this themselves. You could go on a YouTube video and you could learn how to make this yourself.
So you don't ever really know what the dosage that you're getting in the oil is. Now if you make it
yourself or you know somebody that made it, you know what they used as the extracted. So how it's made
and recommend if you're looking into this, that you do a little research, that you go on YouTube,
search out how to make rick Simpson oil. And you watch some of the videos, even if you're not going to
make it yourself, to see how it's made. The marijuana buds are put in a bucket and you have to
use some sort of extracted that you smash down the buds with an extracted rick Simpson uses
deathfully I think. Other people use 100% alcohol and then that is used. You need to have a
pretty strong extracted to get the THC out of the bud. So that smash down in a bucket and then it's
poured off which so you're getting that extracted plus the THC that's dissolved in the extracted
and then you put that in a rice cooker and you cook that down and there's a procedure that you do
with it. You have to do it outside because it's extremely flammable to explode your house. So you have to
do it outside where there's a fan or a wind or a breeze and you cook that down and it takes basically
a good day process to get down to where you have this oil that is hopefully free of the extracted
because you boiled it all off over that day's period. So the extracted is out of that oil and all
you have left is the THC in this black paste. Now a problem occurs as you can think about it that
how do you know that you've actually purified this black paste from the extracted?
The answer is you don't. You could have a reaction. So some of the negative reactions to the THC
oil I believe come into not so much a negative reaction to the THC so that is extremely possible as
well but you could have a negative reaction to some left over extracted in the oil. So I'll give you
an example of somebody that I know intimately that tried THC oil as an experiment. It is
person that I know intimately tried the THC oil and had a very negative reaction and this person thought
well maybe he overdosed on it and used too much of it maybe that was the negative reaction because
part of the negative reaction was the loopiness or highness that you would get with high dose THC
which is not extremely comfortable in itself but the other part of the negative reaction was
was a lot of other issues too just muscle jerky that's muscle twitching are able to sit still feeling
pleasy feeling sick feeling like you are basically being poisoned to death and that's no fun
in wondering if you should close your eyes and go to sleep because you probably won't wake up.
So those reactions are I guess you're able to live with it if you know that the THC is killing
the cancer but if you're just experimenting with it you wonder whether this is a good idea or not.
So this person tried a lower dosage still had not the loopiness reaction but had the other symptoms the
other side effects the feeling like it was toxic feeling like it was poisoned tried even a lower dose
multiple different times tried using coconut oil with it tried it as a suppository tried multiple
different ways with the THC oil that he had still had these reactions then thought well maybe it is
the oil that he had and maybe it wasn't completely purified or maybe because it wasn't completely
purified there was a toxic reaction to the extracted or maybe there was a allergic reaction to the
extracted that was still in the oil. So this person waited a few weeks and received a different batch
from a different source completely different area completely to her company and tried it again
in a very very low dose much lower dose that he started before still had very similar reactions
and when he slowly ramped up on the dose as is directed those same reactions took place. So
then this person thought well maybe it's the THC and not the extracted because the chance of these two
people two companies using the same extracted I guess it still exists but so still the possibility
of an allergic reaction to the extracted exists but certainly it just didn't seem valuable to
continue with the THC when this person thought they weren't going to die of the cancer they were going
to die of the cure and that wasn't extremely desirable so this person decided to stop this
experiment and to the point of how sick this person felt one day was the only day that this person
missed work after being diagnosed with cancer for about 20 months that decided that this was not
the treatment of choice and after stopping it symptoms dissipated and a problem that this person
was having it was resolved and back to his normal state so I'll all act to say I think Rick Simpson
Oil is a viable treatment option for many people you cannot go on the internet without hearing
numerous stories of people that were quote unquote healed from cancer using Rick Simpson Oil but you
don't get the stories from this person that I'm speaking about because they don't tell their stories
on the internet when something didn't work like this so it's you just have to take all these things
with a partial grade of salt again I think it's a viable treatment option for some people and even if
you test out for it because this person that were speaking up had had the violent reaction to it
did test out positive for it but it didn't work with that person's body so even though it would kill
this person's cancer that person couldn't tolerate the oil so it wasn't the treatment of viable option
as well so that all to say I am still very pro Rick Simpson oil pro THC we're not talking about CBD
here we're only talking about THC except you have to test it out for yourself even if you test
positive on it you're going to start very very slow and work up to dosage and still you might not
be able to tolerate it now I've heard this from other patients as well okay I've had numerous
patients that have tolerated it well but I've also had numerous patients that didn't tolerate it
at all and quit taking it because of lack of tolerance to it they did not like the way it made them
feel they got horrible symptoms because of it and it just was not a viable option okay so hopefully
that answers most of the questions on that I'm going to unmute everybody and you could ask
separate questions or questions from what we were speaking about I have a question Dr. Connors
uh huh this is crystal and we spoke about this before but why would a person have mucus
in their stools so why would a person have mucus in their stools so mucus in your stools
um it can't be caused from uh eating dairy so if a person is eating a lot of mucus foremeat
material they can have mucus in their stools mucus in their stools can be caused for
but inflammatory process in the stools like ulcerative colitis or other inflammatory bowel diseases
um so then you start looking at because a person could have more than one problem going on
right okay so just because a person has cancer we have to be careful not to be so narrow-minded
that a person can't have another thing going on so one thing that I would recommend if a person
tonight have mucus stools I would experiment with some dietary changes first um and uh look at
mucus foremeat food look at something that could be irritated I would go uh in the differential
diagnosis category I'd go where did the mucus or where did the mucus of the stool start well to
start it three months ago well did I change anything at that time did my diet change at all a couple
months before that um and then look at other things that could cause dietary or uh gut irritation
which can be basically any food can cause gut irritation so a good thing to do is to run a
food sensitivity test uh like syrex lab array 10 which would test for about 300 different peptides
in different foods and you just can blow your mind what you could come back positive on
and then you could go wow I eat that every day and by changing your diet it could make a big difference
so um those are the most kind of things okay thank you
dr. counters continuing on that with the coffee animal if your um
genes are mutated about 50% cause mucus and your stools also
what's if you're caught if you're doing the coffee animal and you have uh a genetic mutation on your
genes that uh detox caffeine you mean yes no that wouldn't cause any mucus for the stools at all
so if you have a genetic defect on the cytochrome p450 gene that um it is responsible for detoxing
caffeine you actually detox caffeine better than somebody who doesn't have the defect so
that's one of those defects that if you have a defect on that gene you detox the caffeine
more readily so if you don't have defects on those genes that you don't detox caffeine as readily
but even if you did not have any defects on that gene and you were drinking coffee
and you were doing coffee animals it wouldn't cause mucus for the stools it would cause
your body to retain the caffeine in the bloodstream more and you'd have more bloodstream
caffeine issues like jitteredis and high blood pressure issues and uncomfortableness
and anxiety issues uh it wouldn't be bowel issues you're not detoxified it
okay it's not causing inflammation
this is jaren i have a question um is there like maybe just a handful of supplements or you know
nutrients suitables that we could feel assured that every day we're getting our real basic vitamins like
i know like i'm using the greens first and um the sun spectrum and all of
some of those things that you give them to me but well if a person would be like if a person let's say
was um tube feed because they couldn't eat anything so they have to be fed by a tube i mean that's
like worst-case scenario how are we going to get this person they're a best source of nutrients
because they're not eating anything um uh we have we have created some tube feeding
protocols using greens first and protein powder the protein enzyme and a few other things um so
you know that's the worst case scenario an average person by if you're doing greens first every day
um and you're still eating some food you're getting you're getting your nutrition so that's
when a person says to me hey i just want to take a multiple let's say a non-cancer person
what should i do for the best multiple should i take this multiple vitamin that's
typically going to be all synthetic supplements my answer is uh no that's not a good source
so you want a whole food source if it all possible and greens first is one of the better
whole food sources there's another whole food supplement's out there too which greens versus yeah there's
a good one yeah just go ahead because thought like the vitamin companies certainly tempt you because
you know they run down the whole list of what percentage of everything you're getting and they're
listing abc you know what i mean it's sure you don't see that necessarily on the supplements but it
doesn't mean you're not getting what you need but you don't see like whether you're getting the daily
recommended dose of all of those things so that's right and you certainly don't want a synthetic
source of that the only thing that you don't get as much of in the greens first is more of your
fat soluble vitamins and that's why that we use that uh that new d uh three from allergy resource
that has all the fat fat soluble vitamins in that d has the k has the the a the e and the d
the k so it has all your fat soluble vitamins in there what is that called it's a it's called
d three complete oh okay it's a it's a capsule um because i've been um you know taking
d supplements and not elevating my level in my blood work and then i started taking liquid drops from
um uh like kind of a holistic type chiropractor who some of the same supplements you do here
but um that sounds even better because it would cover more ground yeah so you do need to get your
back roll molecules in your fats into so um make sure you're eating coconut oil and you're
cooking with coconut oil and some good fats and like that as well any other questions
dr. com oops dr. Conner yes um getting back to vitamin c with lipisol where do you feel about that
this is Liz Schaffner and Michigan so you're talking about lipo zomal vitamin c so lipo zomal vitamin c if
you're going to take oral vitamin c that's that's much more preferred so using lipo zomal vitamin c
so lipo zomal anything is that nutrient wrapped in a fat that's what lipo zomal means
so vitamin c wrapped in a fat is much have a has a much higher absorption rate so it is much more
preferred than just taking vitamin c so very good thank you what would you say the recommended
daily dose of that would be well if you're trying to take it as an antioxidant mean just to protect
yourselves then you can take a thousand to two thousand milligrams a day would be fun if you're
trying to replicate iv vitamin c meaning there's some people that want to do iv vitamin c but
they don't have the veins for it irritates their their veins they can't take it but they're trying to
use lipo zomal vitamin c to replicate it so let's take a step back you cannot take enough oral vitamin c
to replicate the dose of iv vitamin c the people will go wait a second i'm taking 20 grams of vitamin c
a day so why is that not replicating the dose of 20 grams of iv vitamin c because if you took 20 grams
of vitamin c orally a day you'll probably only absorb about three thousand milligrams or three grams
of that maybe four to five grams of it maybe a fifth to a fourth of that though if you take lipozomal
vitamin c the reason why it's so much better than regular vitamin c is your absorption rate is so much
higher you'll probably absorb about 70 percent of it so yes if you took 20 grams of lipozomal vitamin c
a day that's equivalent to maybe taking you know six getting a 16 gram dose of iv vitamin c though it's
acting more it's a higher enough dose than it's acting as an oxidizing agent and it can really have
more effect on the cancer itself however it would be hard on your tummy like vitamin c can be students
not to watch them okay very interesting thank you for that information
Dr. Cahns this is Deb on sports from oil um if you're you're not you never recommend cod liver oil
for to get our quality fats is that a quick thing to take or not it can't be that's another source
using cod liver oil i would suggest that fermented cod liver oil by green pan
green pastures i think it is it's the kind that has that that would be the one that i would use
but that could be another good source of your good fats yes you could use that
it does is it have that and the ripe proper k2 oh no i don't think it does that's going to be
mainly a source of obegas okay anything else all right all right well i think we'll wrap this up
make sure you post any questions on facebook that you might have and um uh we will see you again next week
bye bye everybody thank you you're welcome bye bye